Tasha: 交
Tasha: Pay
其他人：交易费
Others: Transaction fee
Tasha: 哦哦我知道
Tasha: Oh, I know
Tasha: 可以
Tasha: Alright
Tasha: 这对空气是有意义的
Tasha: This has some significance for the air
Tasha: 嗯有意义
Tasha: Yeah, meaningful
Tasha: 两块钱一个
Tasha: Two yuan each
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
其他人：你要多少
Others: How many do you want?
其他人：就一个没问题
Others: Just one, no problem
Tasha: 要一个
Tasha: I want one
Tasha: 这也没问题
Tasha: That's fine
其他人：我跟你说
Others: Let me tell you
其他人：你现在是两块钱买
Others: You are buying for two yuan now
其他人：随便转不找
Others: You can transfer without change
Tasha: 是的好
Tasha: Yes, okay
Tasha: 真的
Tasha: Really
其他人：你找到两块钱都找不着啊
Others: You can't even find two yuan
Tasha: 哈哈哈不是
Tasha: Hahaha, no
Tasha: 万一没有一个人买怎么办
Tasha: What if no one buys it?
Tasha: 不是这有什么
Tasha: Isn't this
Tasha: 这有什么用
Tasha: What's the point of this?
Tasha: 这有什么用啊
Tasha: What's the use of this?
Tasha: 谁谁
Tasha: Who
Tasha: 像个像个宣传组织
Tasha: Like a promotional organization
Tasha: 那虚拟货币它最终有什么用呢
Tasha: So what's the use of virtual currency in the end?
Tasha: 比如比特币
Tasha: Like Bitcoin
Tasha: 就当现实的钱来花吗
Tasha: Do you just spend it like real money?
Tasha: 嗯那我如果花两块钱买一个
Tasha: Hmm, so if I spend two yuan to buy one
Tasha: 我可以用一个ego币
Tasha: Can I use an ego coin
Tasha: 去买一瓶矿泉水吗
Tasha: to buy a bottle of mineral water?
其他人：可以啊只要矿泉水的拥有者
Others: Yes, as long as the owner of the mineral water
其他人：他认可了你的币
Others: accepts your coin.
Tasha: 哦这样子啊
Tasha: Oh, I see.
其他人：一切都建立在一个互相共识的机制上
Others: Everything is based on a mutual consensus mechanism.
Tasha: 啊这样子
Tasha: Ah, I get it.
Tasha: 懂了
Tasha: Understood.
Tasha: 我相信你
Tasha: I believe you.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
其他人：不是不是不是
Others: No, no, no.
其他人：另外一个女的
Others: It's another woman.
其他人：我们是把那150个全藏了
Others: We hid all 150 coins.
Jake:不不不藏20个
Jake: No, no, no, hide 20 coins.
Tasha: 那150个ego币
Tasha: Those 150 ego coins.
其他人：你让他们非死非活只能找到20个币
Others: You make them struggle and only find 20 coins.
Tasha: 那比特币的话
Tasha: What about Bitcoin?
Tasha: 最后
Tasha: In the end...
Jake:不不不剩剩下的
Jake: No, no, no, the rest,
Jake:他们要赚钱
Jake: they need to earn money.
Jake:就是他们要打体赚钱
Jake: They need to work to earn money.
Tasha: 一开始是谁把他们炒起来捧红的呢
Tasha: So who promoted and made them popular at the beginning?
Jake:所以150个差不多
Jake: So 150 is about right.
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: I have no idea.
Tasha: 那人家创始人跟我们这创始人不一样
Tasha: The founders are different from our founders.
Tasha: 所以
Tasha: So...
其他人：比特币牛逼啊
Others: Bitcoin is awesome.
Tasha: 价值提升也不一样吧
Tasha: The value increase is different too, right?
Tasha: 虚拟货币的人
Tasha: People in virtual currency...
Tasha: 虚拟货币可能以后用在元宇宙比较多
Tasha: Virtual currency might be used more in the metaverse in the future.
Tasha: 是吗
Tasha: Right?
Tasha: 就建立那套经济体系嘛
Tasha: Just to establish that economic system.
Tasha: 就用虚拟货币
Tasha: Using virtual currency.
Tasha: 所以以后币是不是越来越多
Tasha: So will there be more coins in the future?
Tasha: 开创一个ego小镇
Tasha: Create an ego town.
Tasha: 然后跟比特小镇建立联盟关系
Tasha: Then establish an alliance with Bitcoin town.
Tasha: 哈哈哈然后有一个统一的货币银行
Tasha: Hahaha, then there will be a unified currency bank.
Tasha: 可以进行一个汇率转换
Tasha: To handle currency exchange rates.
其他人：没有没有
Others: No, no.
其他人： 这个
Others: That...
其他人：虚拟货币的核心目标就是把银行干掉
Other: The core goal of virtual currency is to eliminate banks.
其他人：就是我们在网上买任何的币都是
Other: That means whenever we buy any currency online,
其他人：都是PUP的哦
Other: it's all PUP.
其他人：所以中国给他干掉
Other: That's why China eliminated it.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Tasha: 确实而且中国有好多实体经济
Tasha: Indeed, and China has a lot of real economy.
Tasha: 他就不允许袁云舟的出现
Tasha: So it doesn't allow the emergence of Yuan Yunzhou.
Tasha: 在大力打
Tasha: They're cracking down hard.
Tasha: 大力打击
Tasha: Cracking down hard.
Tasha: 他就是想要实体经济嘛
Tasha: They just want a real economy.
其他人：只要未来太发达了
Other: As long as the future is too advanced,
其他人：每个人能一秒钟瞬移过来
Other: everyone could teleport in a second.
其他人：觉自由基就挺好
Other: Free radicals would be great.
其他人：现在网络上自由基太可怕了
Other: Now, free radicals on the internet are terrifying.
其他人：因为他这一般是先把币给的
Other: Because they usually give the currency first.
其他人：然后在银行卡打钱
Other: Then transfer money into the bank account.
Tasha: 不错很看好你们的项目
Tasha: Not bad, I'm optimistic about your project.
Tasha: 我投两块钱哈哈哈
Tasha: I'll invest two bucks, hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Jake:你过了五年吧
Jake: Give it five years.
其他人：过了三年你就买不到了
Other: In three years, you won't be able to buy it.
Tasha: 真的吗好
Tasha: Really? Okay.
Tasha: 那我再加注5块
Tasha: Then I'll add five more bucks.
其他人：从第一个人找到第一个币
Other: From the first person who found the first currency,
其他人：那个就已经变了
Other: it has already changed.
Jake:噢噢噢
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Tasha: 行那我投10块
Tasha: Okay, I'll invest ten bucks.
其他人：没问题 10块钱买一个币啊
Other: No problem, ten bucks for one currency.
Tasha: 啊又10块钱买一个了
Tasha: Ah, I bought another one for ten bucks.
Tasha: 怎么这么低起价
Tasha: Why is it so cheap?
Tasha: 不如两块钱一个啊可以
Tasha: Why not two bucks for one? That works too.
其他人：十块钱买5个币
Other: Ten bucks for five currencies.
Jake:呵买游戏币
Jake: Haha, buying game currency.
Jake:当游戏
Jake: Just like a game.
Jake:那个那边走
Jake: Move over there.
Jake:哎这什么神奇走位
Jake: Hey, what kind of magical move is this?
Jake:跑错了跑错了
Jake: Went the wrong way, went the wrong way.
Jake:你干嘛呢
Jake: What are you doing?
Jake:要买东西啊
Jake: You need to buy things.
Jake:踏进去了
Jake: Stepped in.
Tasha: 这么多快递
Tasha: So many packages.
Tasha: 彩票店呢
Tasha: Where's the lottery shop?
Jake:嗯彩票
Jake: Hmm, lottery.
Tasha: 彩票店呢
Tasha: Where's the lottery shop?
Jake:彩票店那边
Jake: The lottery shop is over there.
Jake:不着急不着急
Jake: No rush, no rush.
Jake:先取快递
Jake: Let's get the packages first.
Jake:在哪
Jake: Where are they?
Tasha: 先取快递
Tasha: Let's get the packages first.
Jake:然后再刮彩票
Jake: Then we'll scratch the lottery tickets.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Tasha: 我负责取我的
Tasha: I'll get mine.
Tasha: 你负责取群里面其他人的是吧
Tasha: You get the others' from the group, right?
Jake:呃不差不多了
Jake: Uh, not exactly.
Jake:不是你你这边取20个
Jake: No, you pick up 20 here.
Jake:别人取4个
Jake: Others pick up 4.
Jake:那你取20个
Jake: You get 20.
Jake:我们取4个
Jake: We get 4.
Jake:我们一人取两个
Jake: We each get two.
其他人：好你有20个
Others: Okay, you have 20.
Jake:他有20个
Jake: He's got 20.
Jake:他是真牛逼
Jake: He's amazing.
Tasha: 没有人替我取啊
Tasha: No one is picking up for me?
Jake:我们我们
Jake: We, we...
Jake:就算替你取
Jake: We'll pick up for you.
Jake:我感觉昨天取不过来
Jake: I feel like we couldn't pick them all up yesterday.
Jake:但是今天我们三个人要打车了
Jake: But today, the three of us need to take a taxi.
Jake:我估计
Jake: I guess.
Jake:不要了不要了看看瞧
Jake: No, no, let's see.
Tasha: 我买的性价比都很高
Tasha: What I bought has great value.
Tasha: 你知道吧
Tasha: You know?
Tasha: 500块钱
Tasha: 500 yuan.
Tasha: 9707
Tasha: 9707.
Tasha: 没查到
Tasha: Couldn't find it.
Tasha: 我们是去养老院呀
Tasha: We're going to the nursing home?
Jake:养啊养老院是什么
Jake: Nursing home? What's that?
Jake:这不是养老院
Jake: This isn't a nursing home.
Jake:养老院在哪
Jake: Where's the nursing home?
其他人：那个哦
Others: That one, oh.
Jake:那个就都都都在那吗
Jake: Is that all there?
其他人：一个没有啊
Others: There's none.
Jake:邻里驿站是那个
Jake: The neighborhood station is that one.
其他人：那个
Others: That one.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:这么回事
Jake: So that's how it is.
Jake:他他的这些都在
Jake: All of his stuff is here.
Jake:你都在
Jake: You're all here.
Tasha: 都在养老院
Jake:我靠再见我
Jake: Damn, goodbye me.
Tasha: 你你你你真的认识路吗
Tasha: Do you really know the way?
Jake:认识我认识
Jake: I know, I know.
Jake:我认识
Jake: I know.
Tasha: 我真认识
Tasha: I really know.
Tasha: 你真的不会走错路吗
Tasha: Are you sure you won't get lost?
Tasha: 我绝对不会走错的
Tasha: I definitely won't get lost.
Jake:这这是真道啊
Jake: This is the right way.
Jake:一般都是在这先切磋一遍
Jake: Usually, we practice here first.
Jake:我怎么知道你都在
Jake: How would I know you're all here?
Jake:就是一个菜鸟都没有啊
Jake: There's not even a newbie here.
Jake:是吧
Jake: Right?
Jake:一个菜鸟都没有
Jake: Not a single newbie.
Jake:你看看还有多少电
Jake: Check how much battery is left.
Jake:卧槽我他妈没冲啊
Jake: Damn, I didn't charge it.
Jake:还有多少
Jake: How much is left?
Tasha: 没看到呀
Tasha: I can't see it.
Tasha: 还有多少呢
Tasha: How much is left?
Tasha: 35
Tasha: 35.
Jake:35
Jake: 35.
Tasha: thirty five
Tasha: Thirty-five.
Tasha: 35
Tasha: 35.
Jake:怎么好
Jake: That's good.
Tasha: 这么好我给二年级小孩辅导哎哈哈
Tasha: That's great, I'm tutoring second graders, haha.
Jake:这么牛逼
Jake: That's impressive.
Jake:多少钱
Jake: How much?
Tasha: 200块钱一个小时
Tasha: 200 RMB per hour.
Jake:卧槽
Jake: Damn.
Jake:我应该我应该也会
Jake: I think I can do it too.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Tasha: 对啊
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake:二年级小孩我应该还能hold住的
Jake: I should still be able to handle second graders.
Tasha: 是的呀
Tasha: Yes.
Jake:哈哈哈初中
Jake: Hahaha, middle schoolers...
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake:为什么hold不住的
Jake: Why can't I handle them?
其他人：有点难
Others: It's a bit hard.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:小学小学
Jake: Elementary school, elementary school.
Jake:你教什么
Jake: What do you teach?
Jake:哈喽are you from Singapore
Jake: Hello, are you from Singapore?
Tasha: 教书本上的内容哈哈哈
Tasha: Teaching the stuff in the books, hahaha.
Jake:200块钱
Jake: 200 bucks.
Jake:他家长为什么这么有钱
Jake: Why are their parents so rich?
Tasha: 北京你搞不懂的
Tasha: It's Beijing, you wouldn't understand.
Tasha: 如果我是名师我就1,000块一个小时了
Tasha: If I were a famous teacher, I'd charge 1,000 bucks an hour.
Jake:咳
Jake: Cough.
Jake:小学二年级1,000块钱一小时
Jake: 1,000 bucks an hour for second grade?
Tasha: 小学是小学是200多啊
Tasha: Elementary school is more like 200 something.
Jake:初中
Jake: Middle school.
Tasha: 初中就是四五百了
Tasha: Middle school is about 400-500.
Jake:四五百一小时
Jake: 400-500 an hour?
Tasha: 嗯高中名校一节课3,000
Tasha: Yeah, high school at a prestigious school is 3,000 a session.
Jake:一节课是多久
Jake: How long is a session?
Jake:45分钟一个小时 3,000
Jake: 45 minutes to an hour, 3,000 bucks?
Tasha: 一个小时吧
Tasha: About an hour.
Tasha: 1.5个小时
Tasha: 1.5 hours.
Tasha: 当然是一对一了
Tasha: Of course, it's one-on-one.
Jake:一个人吧
Jake: One person, right?
Jake:一对一
Jake: One-on-one.
Jake:一小时3,000
Jake: 3,000 an hour.
Tasha: 你要是名师OK
Tasha: If you're a famous teacher, okay.
Jake:名师是得多名
Jake: How famous do you have to be?
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: I don't know.
Tasha: 我不是
Tasha: I'm not one.
Tasha: 我也教不高
Tasha: I don't teach high school.
Tasha: 教不了高中
Tasha: I can't teach high school.
Tasha: 没有了解过那方面
Tasha: I haven't looked into that.
Jake:哦高中
Jake: Oh, high school.
Jake:太难了hold不住了
Jake: It's too hard, I can't hold on anymore.
Tasha: 我之前还看到一条消息说呃
Tasha: I saw a message before that said, um...
Tasha: 过年十天
Tasha: During the ten days of the New Year...
Tasha: 就是从大年初三到大年初十三
Tasha: From the third to the thirteenth day of the lunar new year.
Jake:还大年初三
Jake: The third day of the lunar new year?
Jake:找啥子头啥子头
Jake: What are you talking about?
Tasha: 找一个清华北大的什么山
Tasha: Find a Tsinghua or Peking University student, something like that...
Tasha: 然后住家住十天是多少万
Tasha: And live with them for ten days, how many tens of thousands would that cost?
Tasha: 真的
Tasha: Really.
Tasha: 当时这条信息我看到
Tasha: When I saw that message...
Tasha: 只恨自己不是清华北大的
Tasha: I just hated that I wasn't from Tsinghua or Peking University.
Tasha: 不然就跑到人家家住10天
Tasha: Otherwise, I'd go live at someone's house for ten days.
Jake:可以啊
Jake: That works.
Tasha: 哦这呢
Tasha: Oh, here it is.
其他人：包食住2万10天
Others: All-inclusive for food and stay, 20,000 for ten days.
Tasha: 包吃住2万10天
Tasha: All-inclusive for food and stay, 20,000 for ten days.
Jake:2万10天
Jake: 20,000 for ten days.
Jake:那还一般
Jake: That's not bad.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahaha
Jake:不一般不一般
Jake: Not bad at all.
Tasha: 又不是让你24小时教他
Tasha: It's not like you have to teach them 24 hours a day.
Tasha: 一天就教几个小时吧
Tasha: Just teach a few hours a day.
Tasha: 语数英早上一门中午一门晚上一门
Tasha: Chinese, Math, English, one subject in the morning, one at noon, and one at night.
Tasha: 不就学完了
Tasha: Then it's done.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Jake:对我们只能hold住小学跟大学
Jake: Yeah, we can only handle elementary and university levels.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahaha
Tasha: 我也觉得
Tasha: I think so too.
Tasha: 目前我干的也是这两个业务哈
Tasha: That's what I'm doing right now, those two things.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahaha
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha.
Tasha: 这鸡怎么这么懒
Tasha: Why is this chicken so lazy?
Jake:懒
Jake: Lazy.
Tasha: 到现在才开始吃大米
Tasha: It's only now starting to eat rice.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Tasha: 几点了都
Tasha: What time is it already?
Jake:这这怎么就养老院了呢
Jake: How did this turn into a retirement home?
Tasha: 你好 9707
Tasha: Hello, 9707.
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Jake:你是一个一个报啊还是一起报
Jake: Are you reporting one by one or all at once?
Jake:咱不咱
Jake: Are we not...
Jake:咱不在这住
Jake: Are we not living here?
Tasha: 他们刚刚没有菜鸟驿站的快递吗
Tasha: Didn't they just have no Cainiao logistics?
Jake:没有
Jake: No.
Tasha: 对是的
Tasha: Yes, that's right.
Jake:给点给点给点给点
Jake: Give some, give some, give some.
Jake:不给不给
Jake: Not giving, not giving.
Jake:不给就不给了
Jake: If not giving, then not giving.
Tasha: 那等等还有
Tasha: Wait, there's more.
其他人：你都买的什么
Others: What did you buy?
Tasha: 你看嘛
Tasha: Just look.
Jake:你这个收拾你要收拾一天吧
Jake: You're going to spend a whole day sorting this out, right?
Tasha: 所以我很着急
Tasha: That's why I'm in a hurry.
Jake:也对
Jake: True.
Tasha: 昨天晚上我就哭了
Tasha: I cried last night.
Tasha: 来不及了
Tasha: There's no time.
其他人：为什么你的发的太慢了
Others: Why are you so slow in shipping?
其他人： 你买的太慢
Others: You buy too slowly.
Jake:取的太慢
Jake: Picking up too slow.
Tasha: 买太多了
Tasha: Bought too much.
Tasha: 你看如果买只j cat就直接解决了
Tasha: If you just bought J Cat, it would be solved directly.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Tasha: 哎取快递在哪里
Tasha: Hey, where to pick up the package?
Tasha: 看看他们的12
Tasha: Look at their 12.
Tasha: 3
Tasha: 3.
Tasha: 4
Tasha: 4.
Tasha: 哦他们就4个
Tasha: Oh, they just have 4.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
其他人：你取完了
Others: Have you finished picking up?
Jake:你取完了
Jake: Have you finished picking up?
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: I don't know.
Jake:没有我这还有两个呢
Jake: No, I still have two more.
Tasha: 海边奶茶店
Tasha: Beachside milk tea shop.
Tasha: 这是什么
Tasha: What is this?
Tasha: 奶油泡泡盅
Tasha: Cream bubble cup.
Tasha: 这是什么
Tasha: What is this?
Tasha: 17代
Tasha: Generation 17.
Jake:是什么
Jake: What is it?
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: I don't know.
Jake:这是你的吗
Jake: Is this yours?
Jake:是你的
Jake: It's yours.
Jake:不知道是真牛逼
Jake: I don't know, it's really impressive.
Jake:放也放一下哈
Jake:我觉得我不行啊
Jake: I don't think I can do it.
其他人：卧槽
Others: Whoa!
Jake:你你能行啊
Jake: You, you can do it.
Jake:我是不行的
Jake: I can't do it.
Jake:我们要分好几趟
Jake: We need to split it into several trips.
Jake:打车我估计
Jake: Probably need to take a cab.
其他人：卧槽
Others: Whoa!
其他人：我草你是我姐
Others: Whoa, you're my sister.
Jake:你你是我姐
Jake: You, you're my sister.
Jake:你小子你还能住一天啊
Jake: Kid, you can stay another day.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
其他人：哈哈
Others: Haha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Tasha: 退掉一下吧
Tasha: Just cancel it.
Tasha: 现在就退掉
Tasha: Cancel it now.
Jake:取没取完没关系
Jake: It's fine if it's not all taken.
Jake:你拿走你拿
Jake: Just take what you need.
Jake:拿回宿舍去
Jake: Take it back to the dorm.
Jake:或者够我一点
Jake: Or give me a bit.
Tasha: 分你一点啊
Tasha: Give you a bit?
Jake:分我一点啊
Jake: Give me a bit?
Tasha: 行分你
Tasha: Sure, I'll give you some.
Tasha: 你到时候看中啥就直接拿走
Tasha: Just take what you like when the time comes.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 还有吗
Tasha: Is there more?
Jake:你自己的还没弄完呢
Jake: You haven't finished your own stuff yet.
Jake:嘿嘿
Jake: Hehe.
Jake:来的不巧啊
Jake: Bad timing.
Tasha: 你等会把群里面的报一下吧
Tasha: Report it in the group later.
Tasha: 我不好意思了
Tasha: I'm embarrassed.
Jake:我来包我来包我来包
Jake: I'll pack, I'll pack, I'll pack.
Jake:你不放一会啊
Jake: Aren't you gonna put it down for a bit?
Jake:啊没有
Jake: Oh no.
Tasha: 上面还有两个哎哦哦
Tasha: There are still two on top, oh oh.
Jake:哦不不不
Jake: Oh no no no.
Jake:就这俩然后姜维亚俩
Jake: Just these two, then Ginger and Wei.
Tasha: 还有吗
Tasha: Are there any more?
Tasha: 还有几个
Tasha: How many more are there?
Tasha: 还有几个啊那就好
Tasha: How many more? Oh, that's good.
Jake:可以
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 这什么
Tasha: What's this?
Jake:这什么这什么点点
Jake: What's this? What's this? Point it out.
Tasha: 这是什么
Tasha: What is this?
Jake:好我又有了啊
Jake: Alright, I got another one.
Tasha: 不知道呀洋甘菊
Tasha: I don't know, chamomile.
Jake:7这个 735003235003
Jake: 7, this 735003235003.
Tasha: 你看这个买了之后清明节还能再用上
Tasha: Look, we can use this again during Qingming Festival.
Tasha: 啊清明节下一年啊
Tasha: Oh, next year's Qingming Festival.
Jake:清明节
Jake: Qingming Festival.
其他人：你他妈这么早过清明节啊
Others: Are you celebrating Qingming Festival this early?
Tasha: 清明节下一年了吗
Tasha: Is it already next year's Qingming Festival?
其他人：这么早过清明节
Others: Celebrating Qingming Festival this early?
Tasha: 你看这刚好用得上
Tasha: Look, it's just perfect for it.
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Jake:这么刚好啊
Jake: Just perfect, huh?
Jake:呵呵呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Tasha: 啊什么
Tasha: What?
Jake:这么刚好啊
Jake: Just perfect, huh?
Jake:呵呵还有啊
Jake: Haha, there’s more.
Jake:132563和722563
Jake: 132563 and 722563.
Tasha: 真的吗那我现在退了吧
Tasha: Really? Then I should return it now.
Jake:来再来两个
Jake: Come on, get two more.
Jake:我们规划一下吧
Jake: Let's plan a bit.
Jake:想想办法
Jake: Think of a way.
Tasha: 没想到我们取完
Tasha: Didn't expect that after we finished,
Tasha: 后面已经堆了这么多人了
Tasha: there would be so many people behind us.
Jake:不是我们的啊
Jake: Not ours, huh?
Jake:呃72呃 2563和132563 嗯
Jake: Uh, 72, uh, 2563 and 132563, hmm.
其他人：好吧
Others: Okay.
Jake:牛批一个抵5个
Jake: Awesome, one equals five.
Jake:咱还没取完呢咱
Jake: We haven't finished yet.
Jake:咱太能买了咱
Jake: We can really buy a lot.
Jake:好没了
Jake: Alright, that's it.
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Jake:几个啊这是
Jake: How many are these?
Jake:4个吗刚刚不是拿了两
Jake: Four? Didn't we just take two?
Jake:个吗
Jake: This, right?
Jake:是吧是嗯
Jake: Right, yeah.
Tasha: 是吧
Tasha: Right?
Jake:吓我一跳
Jake: You scared me.
Jake:顺拿一张纸
Jake: Grab a piece of paper.
Tasha: 怎么办嘞
Tasha: What should we do?
Tasha: 怎么办
Tasha: What to do?
Jake:抱走还是打车啊
Jake:抱着走啊
Tasha: 抱着走
Tasha: Pack it up and go.
其他人：那我拿一下啊
Others: I'll grab it.
Jake:完了啊偷不到了
Jake: It's done, can't steal it now.
其他人：呵给我来一个
Others: Hey, give me one.
Tasha: 你东西这么多
Tasha: You have so much stuff.
Tasha: 你你都不忘记
Tasha: You don't forget anything.
其他人：小偷不是偷
Others: Thieves don't steal.
Jake:呵呵读书人
Jake: Haha, scholars.
Tasha: 读书人拿东西叫偷吗
Tasha: Do scholars taking things count as stealing?
Jake:对读书人呢
Jake: Yeah, scholars.
Tasha: 各取所需罢了
Tasha: Just taking what they need.
Jake:这个能捡
Jake: This can be picked up.
Jake:这个能放进去吗
Jake: Can this be put in?
Jake:这是要剪啊
Jake: Does this need to be cut?
Jake:一会要系一下啊
Jake: It needs to be tied later.
Jake:啊呵呵呵
Jake: Ah, hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈走吧
Tasha: Haha, let's go.
Tasha: 给我给我给我
Tasha: Give me, give me, give me.
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Tasha: 还刮彩票吗
Jake:刮不了了
Tasha: 我跟你说这个寓意叫满载而归
Tasha: I'm telling you, it means you'll return with a full load.
Tasha: 你现在去彩彩彩票店
Tasha: If you go to the lottery store now.
Tasha: 就可以刮100万回家
Jake:那你刮不到一百万你在那边刮
Jake: If you can't scratch 1 million, you scratch there.
Jake:啊你刮不到100万你就在那边刮
Jake:哈哈哈啊
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
其他人：你觉得那要有几百万我自己拿全款
Others: If you think there's millions, I'd take the full amount.
其他人：没有的话你给我报销
Others: If there's none, you reimburse me.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha.
其他人：有的话分你99万
Other People: If there is, I'll give you 990,000.
其他人：我拿1万就行
Other People: I'll just take 10,000.
Tasha: 今天星期几啊
Tasha: What day is it today?
Jake:星期天
Jake: It's Sunday.
Tasha: 今天星期天
Tasha: Today is Sunday.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yep.
Tasha: 怎么了怎么了怎么了
Tasha: What's going on, what's going on, what's going on?
Tasha: 再扔一个上来
Tasha: Throw another one up here.
Jake:小事求之做
Jake: Small things are easy to do.
Jake:哦怎么怎么偷啊
Jake: Oh, how do you steal it?
Tasha: 打火机偷了一个好漂亮
Tasha: Stole a lighter, it's so pretty.
Jake:哦这一段到底怎么处理
Jake: Oh, how do we handle this part?
Jake:哈哈哈哈就是之前秀说就是打打嘴炮
Jake: Hahaha, just like before, Shure said just talk trash.
Jake:我们这把是真的哈哈哈
Jake: This time we're serious, hahaha.
Jake:你要不跟这个东西见面面去
Jake: Why don't you go meet this thing?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Jake:这东西怎么弄
Jake: How do we deal with this thing?
Jake:喂
Jake: Hello?
Jake:这两把眼镜
Jake: These two pairs of glasses.
Jake:就比方说回去之后看到这就别人
Jake: For example, after we go back and see this, it's others.
其他人：是个黑颜色个
Other People: It's a black color one.
其他人：个信号
Other People: A signal.
其他人：以上都跟被被被窃人商量好的基本
Other People: All of the above were basically agreed upon with the stolen person.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:可以
Jake: Okay.
Jake:当然你说会不会有人自己看呢
Jake: Of course, you say will anyone watch it themselves?
Jake:啊哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Ahahahahahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
其他人：见怪不怪了嗯
Other People: Not surprising anymore, hmm.
Tasha: 哈哈哈我看你的快递都到脖子了
Tasha: Hahaha, I see your packages are piled up to your neck.
Tasha: 还好三个
Tasha: Luckily, only three.
Jake:嗯你要昨天让我们领年华
Jake: Hmm, if you had asked us to pick them up yesterday.
Jake:我觉得你回去日子不太好过
Jake: I think you wouldn't have had a good time going back.
Tasha: 人昨天也就12个
Tasha: There were only 12 people yesterday.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 你都不知道我在学校
Tasha: You don't even know, at school.
Tasha: 我买烘焙东西买了80多个
Tasha: I bought over 80 baking items.
Tasha: 我一个人取完的
Tasha: I picked them all up by myself.
Jake:你怎么去
Jake: How did you go?
Jake:你分几层啊
Jake: How many trips did you make?
其他人：那么小的学校
Other: Such a small school
其他人：要买电瓶车哈哈哈
Other: Need to buy an electric scooter, hahaha
Jake:你分几趟取的
Jake: How many trips did you make?
Tasha: 我一天去取20个
Tasha: I pick up 20 packages a day
Jake:一天取20个
Jake: 20 packages a day
Jake:80个发视频是吧
Jake: 80 packages for a video, right?
Jake:呵呵取货发视频
Jake: Haha, pick up packages, make videos
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Hahaha
Tasha: 我每天取快递拆快递就要一个小时
Tasha: It takes me an hour every day to pick up and unpack packages
Tasha: 我真受不了了
Tasha: I really can't take it anymore
Tasha: 什么时候结工钱呀
Tasha: When will we get paid?
Tasha: 老板
Tasha: Boss
Tasha: 我听说他们都没有在活动前干活了
Tasha: I heard they all stopped working before the event
Jake:什么先先结账
Jake: What, pay first?
Jake:在干活是吧
Jake: Then work, right?
Tasha: 现结着我都把活干完了
Tasha: Pay me now and I'll finish the work
Tasha: 这里只限速5
Tasha: The speed limit here is 5
Jake:我们没超速吧
Jake: We're not speeding, right?
Tasha: 我们
Tasha: We
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Tasha: 首先你要有四个轮子再谈这些
Jake:哈不一定
Jake: Haha, not necessarily
Jake:人应该能够
Jake: A person should be able to
Jake:人一人一小时能能跑5公里
Jake: A person can run 5 km in an hour
Jake:对啊那人是能超速的
Jake: Yeah, a person can exceed the speed limit
Jake:不需要四个轮子
Jake: No need for four wheels
其他人：发一早上消息不搭理我
Other: Sending messages all morning and not replying to me
其他人：就问他为啥不搭理我
Other: Just ask him why he's not replying
其他人：刚看手机
Other: Just saw the phone
其他人：谁信呢
Other: Who believes that
Jake:谁信呢
Jake: Who believes that
Tasha: 受不了了
Tasha: Can't take it anymore
Tasha: 好晒啊
Tasha: It's so sunny
Tasha: 拿得下我说好晒
Tasha: I said it's so sunny
Jake:呐左边一边不是INL
Jake: Look, the left side isn't INL
Tasha: 没事啊彩票店在哪
Tasha: No problem, where's the lottery shop?
Jake:你不是晒吗
Jake: Aren't you complaining about the sun?
Jake:对
Jake: Right
Jake:这彩票店里面
Jake: This lottery shop
Jake:既不晒还能赚钱
Jake: It's not sunny and you can make money
Jake:有可能赚钱
Jake: It might make money.
Jake:基本上亏钱
Jake: But basically, it loses money.
Jake:你赚多少钱
Jake: How much did you make?
Jake:最多
Jake: At most?
Tasha: 100块
Tasha: 100 bucks.
Jake:多少100
Jake: How much, 100?
Jake:100
Jake: 100.
Jake:20块赚100块
Jake: Turn 20 into 100 bucks?
Tasha: 嗯二三十吧
Tasha: Yeah, around 20 or 30.
Tasha: 这是我的最高纪录了
Tasha: That's my highest record.
Jake:嗯牛
Jake: Wow, impressive.
Jake:你刮多少次
Jake: How many times have you scratched?
Tasha: 刮多少次
Jake:你总共刮多少次
Jake: How many times in total?
Jake:有100次吗
Jake: 100 times?
Jake:没有吧 50次 20次
Jake: No way, 50 times? 20 times?
Tasha: 没有吧
Tasha: No way.
Tasha: 20次应该有了吧
Tasha: Maybe around 20 times?
Jake:20次
Jake: 20 times.
Tasha: 出去玩只要走在街
Tasha: Whenever I go out and walk on the street,
Tasha: 街上该溜子就没事干
Tasha: If I have nothing to do, I just scratch another one.
Tasha: 就会继续刮一张
Tasha: I just keep scratching.
Jake:哦就就这个就这个
Jake: Oh, like this, like this.
Tasha: 这不是有体彩吗
Tasha: Isn't there a lottery here?
Tasha: 这不是体彩吗
Tasha: Isn't this the lottery?
Jake:是的是的就是这个
Jake: Yes, yes, this is it.
Jake:不好好上班
Jake: Not working properly.
Tasha: 这个里面吗
Tasha: Is it inside here?
Jake:你试试
Jake: You try it.
Tasha: 哦关门了
Tasha: Oh, it's closed.
Jake:走吧
Jake: Let's go.
Jake:走吧省的10块钱
Jake: Let's go, save 10 bucks.
Jake:省的20块钱
Jake: Save 20 bucks.
Jake:亏他80块钱好吧
Jake: Lose 80 bucks, okay?
Jake:行不行
Jake: Is that okay?
Jake:好了好吧
Jake: Alright, alright.
Tasha: 好了眼镜贴上去了
Tasha: Okay, the glasses are on.
Jake:你可能要充电
Jake: You might need to charge.
Tasha: 充电
Tasha: Charge?
Jake:但是我们三个人
Jake: But the three of us...
Jake:都腾不出任何一只手给你充电
Jake: I can't spare a single hand to charge your phone.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Jake:人手还是太少了
Jake: We're still short-handed.
Tasha: 脚别走路了
Tasha: Use your feet instead of walking.
Jake:暂时用一下也行
Jake: Temporarily using them is fine too.
Tasha: 还有一个行业
Tasha: There's another industry.
Tasha: 你知道KFC代吃吗
Tasha: Do you know about KFC food replacement service?
Tasha: 这个行业
Tasha: This industry...
Jake:卧槽这什么东西
Jake: What the heck is that?
Tasha: KFC代吃
Tasha: KFC food replacement.
Jake:没听说过
Jake: Never heard of it.
Jake:讲讲没听说过
Jake: Tell me about it, I've never heard of it.
Tasha: 没听说过
Tasha: Never heard of it.
Tasha: 你把肯德基吃了
Tasha: You eat the KFC...
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah...
Jake:把肯德基吃了
Jake: Eat the KFC...
Jake:然后呢把玩具寄给别人
Jake: And then you send the toys to others.
Tasha: 把玩具挤给别人就赚钱
Tasha: You make money by sending the toys to others.
Tasha: 这也不知道
Tasha: Didn't you know that?
Jake:专门卖玩具那玩
Jake: They specifically sell those toys.
Tasha: 稳定工艺啊
Tasha: Stable craftsmanship.
Tasha: 哎呦我靠哎呦我靠
Tasha: Oh my god, oh my god.
Tasha: 完了完了
Tasha: We're done, we're done.
Jake:重来吧重来吧
Jake: Let's start over, let's start over.
Jake:重开吧资源重新分配
Jake: Restart and redistribute resources.
Tasha: 资源重新分配
Tasha: Redistribute resources.
Jake:重开给我
Jake: Restart for me.
其他人：正好你充电吧
Others: Just charge your phone then.
Jake:哎可以
Jake: Yeah, sure.
Jake:你把那拿走充电
Jake: Take that and charge it.
Jake:快快
Jake: Hurry, hurry.
Tasha: 累倒了
Tasha: Exhausted.
其他人：是每天都来还是没做
Others: Do you come every day or not?
Tasha: 每次他有活动
Tasha: Every time there's an event.
Jake:这次得拿活动呗
Jake: So you have to attend events.
Tasha: 他活动不是很快吗
Tasha: Aren't the events very quick?
Tasha: 每个节日都有活动
Tasha: Every holiday has an event.
其他人：一天可能吃不了多少
Others: Maybe you won't eat much in a day.
Tasha: 你想吃多少就吃多少
Tasha: You can eat as much as you want.
其他人：那我就买不吃不就行了
Others: Then I just buy it and not eat it.
Tasha: 你怎么可能买光买完就不吃呢
Tasha: How could you buy everything and not eat it?
Jake:会有可能的呀
Jake: It's possible.
Tasha: 他是买套餐送玩具
Tasha: He buys the set meal to get the toy.
Jake:那我就买套餐然后卷掉
Jake: Then I'll just buy the meal and give it away.
Jake:我给homeless people
Jake: I'll give it to homeless people.
Tasha: 聪明的人是把套餐买了
Tasha: Smart people buy the meal,
Tasha: 把玩具分了
Tasha: and then distribute the toys.
Tasha: 然后再把套餐卖给学校里的大学生吃
Tasha: And then sell the meal to college students.
Jake:哦这个也得
Jake: Oh, that works too.
Jake:大学生是个好东西
Jake: College students are great.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha
Tasha: 农村也有
Tasha: Even in rural areas,
Tasha: 自助
Tasha: there's self-service.
Jake:买三瓶可乐
Jake: Buy three bottles of Coke.
Jake:哎我们是是这么走的
Jake: Hey, are we going this way?
Jake:感觉不太对啊
Jake: This doesn't feel right.
Jake:我们拿反了
Jake: We're going the wrong way.
Jake:主要是快递他导的方向不对
Jake: The courier gave us the wrong direction.
Jake:快递到的方向
Jake: The courier's direction.
Jake:哎呀你这个是还有电还是没有电
Jake: Is this still charged or not?
Jake:篮球哎呀我有点粗
Jake: The basketball, oh, I'm a bit rough.
Jake:操你你你
Jake: Damn you, you, you.
Jake:没有电了
Jake: It's out of battery.
Tasha: 哦那我腾出手了
Tasha: Oh, now I have a free hand.
Jake:他能腾住手了
Jake: He has a free hand now.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Jake:你是不是
Jake: Are you...
Jake:你是我姐
Jake: Are you my sister?
Jake:你怎么腾出来的
Jake: How did you free up?
Jake:哈哈哈把我们俩弄的不行了
Jake: Hahaha, we can't handle it anymore.
Jake:一次性就这吗对对对
Jake: Is this a one-time thing? Yeah, yeah.
Jake:你怎么回事
Jake: What's the matter?
Jake:没得电了啊
Jake: Out of battery?
Tasha:  重新创一个
Tasha: Create a new one.
Jake:你是不是没得电了
Jake: Are you out of battery?
Tasha: 是的还有7%的电
Tasha: Yes, it's at 7%.
Tasha: 刚刚是不是关了
Tasha: Did it just turn off?
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Tasha: 开始了
Tasha: It's starting.
Tasha: 五十六个民族五十六朵花
Tasha: Fifty-six ethnic groups, fifty-six flowers.
Tasha: 五十六个中华民族是一家
Tasha: Fifty-six ethnic groups in China are one family.
Jake:好像不太对
Jake: That doesn't seem quite right.
Jake:你是回族
Jake: You're Hui, right?
Tasha: 真的吗那你加多少分
Tasha: Really? How many points do you get?
Jake:那你吃吗
Jake:那你怎么吃啊
Jake:那你什么回族
Jake: What kind of Hui are you?
Jake:身份证回族
Jake: Your ID says Hui?
Jake:加多少分
Jake: How many points do you get?
其他人：就就正好加了5分
Others: Just exactly 5 points.
Tasha: 这还不好啊
Tasha: Isn't that good?
其他人：有什么屌用
Others: What's the use?
Jake:为什么
Jake: Why?
Tasha: 拼死拼活的
Tasha: We worked so hard.
Tasha: 我们小高考都加不了5分
Tasha: We can't even get 5 points in our exams.
Tasha: 得4科考
Tasha: We have to take four subjects.
Jake:为什么高考不加分
Jake: Why don't you get extra points for the college entrance exam?
其他人：我们必须要户口所在地是少数民族集聚区
Others: We have to live in an ethnic minority area.
Tasha: 哎
Tasha: Oh.
Jake:哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, I see.
Jake:那你是哪里啊你是
Jake: Where are you from?
Jake:哎哎呦哎呦
Jake: Oh, oh.
Tasha: 哎呦哎呦
Tasha: Oh, oh.
其他人：我爸是回族是因为他高考能加5分
Others: My dad is Hui because he could get 5 extra points for the college entrance exam.
Tasha: 哎你能分开吗
Tasha: Can you split it?
Jake:我分我分
Jake: I can, I can.
Jake:不哎我现在能分开了
Jake: No, now I can split it.
Jake:但是还是可以有一只手
Jake: But still, I can use one hand.
其他人：我爸就我爸就
Others: My dad, my dad just...
其他人：不吃啊啊
Others: Doesn't eat pork.
其他人：你爸也是啊
Others: Your dad too?
其他人：那从我奶奶开始吃   哦
Others: From my grandma's generation, they started eating pork.
Tasha: 那你有一个
Tasha: So you have a...
Jake:那你有个好
Jake: So you have a good...
Tasha: 桀骜不驯的奶奶
Tasha: Rebellious grandma.
Jake:对你有个好奶奶
Jake: Yeah, you have a good grandma.
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Tasha: 不吃的话你可能比现在更瘦了
Jake:哈哈哈哈有点搞笑
Jake: Hahahaha, that's kind of funny.
Jake:全全国全球公司人还是挺多的
Jake: There are quite a lot of people in national and global companies.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Oh my god
Tasha: 要不这段全程别播了
Tasha: Maybe we shouldn't air this part at all.
Jake:有点搞笑
Jake: It's kinda funny.
Tasha: 柳絮纷飞
Tasha: Willow catkins flying.
Jake:到时候我觉得最后要不还是就是就是
Jake: By then, I think ultimately we should just...
Tasha: 澄清一下
Tasha: Clarify it.
Jake:哔哔哔哈哈哈
Jake: Beep beep beep, hahaha.
Jake:这个数据线当然有点牛逼哈哈哈哈
Jake: This data cable is really impressive, hahaha.
Jake:bb率97%哈
Jake: 97% BB rate, haha.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Jake:哔哔哔哔哔哔
Jake: Beep beep beep beep beep beep.
其他人：我是回族我哔哔
Others: I'm Hui and I beep.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Jake:我我吃哔哔
Jake: I, I eat beep.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahahahahahaha.
Jake:给一个
Jake: Give me one.
Jake:你要帮忙吗
Jake: Do you need help?
Tasha: 嗯这是我什么时候掉下去的
Tasha: Hmm, when did I drop this?
Tasha: 哦重新分配那会
Tasha: Oh, during the redistribution.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:羊肉也蛮好吃的是吧
Jake: Lamb is also quite tasty, right?
Jake:牛羊肉
Jake: Beef and lamb.
Jake:你们有你们海港比回民有基础啊
Jake: Do you guys have a foundation in the harbor, like the Hui?
Jake:还有哎呦我操
Jake: Also, oh my god.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:哦就是还要去那叫什么
Jake: Oh, you still need to go to that... what's it called?
Jake:丝就是保留一下影子素哦
Jake: Silk, just to keep some traces, oh.
Jake:不去那种寺是吧
Jake: Don't go to that kind of temple, right?
Jake:叫回民寺
Jake: Called Hui Temple.
Jake:叫叫什么
Jake: Called what?
Jake:叫回民清真寺
Jake: Called Hui Mosque.
其他人：但是他们虽然还是结婚有影响
Others: But although they're still affected by marriage.
其他人：但是大部分也喝酒
Others: Most of them also drink.
Jake:结婚干嘛
Jake: What's with marriage?
Jake:结婚结婚
Jake: Marriage, marriage.
其他人：回民其实必须得跟回民结婚
Others: Hui people actually have to marry Hui people.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 啊好像不允许跟外族通婚
Tasha: Ah, it seems like intermarriage with outsiders is not allowed.
Jake:oh
Jake: Oh.
其他人：跟我单挑
Others: Challenge me one-on-one.
Jake:他怎么晓得
Jake: How did he know?
Tasha: 你真的认识路吗
Tasha: Do you really know the way?
Tasha: 杨sir
Tasha: Jake.
Jake:人是一半嘛
Jake: It's halfway there.
Jake:这不过半了嘛
Jake: Isn't it more than halfway?
Jake:哈哈这不过半了嘛
Jake: Haha, it's more than halfway.
Jake:是吧认识一大半
Jake: Right? Know most of the way.
Tasha: 和你们在一起被迫学会了识路
Tasha: Being with you guys, I was forced to learn the way.
其他人：没办法我10,000%的路数
Others: No way, I know the routes 10,000%.
Jake:我大概50%
Jake: I know about 50%.
其他人：我就之之前啊有一次
Others: Once, before, I...
其他人：嗯我约我的一个老师去吃饭
Others: Um, I made a lunch date with one of my teachers.
其他人：哎我不晓得
Others: And I didn't know...
其他人：他在学校我直接坐公交车走哦
Others: He was at school, so I just took the bus.
Jake:我们我们回头测一下每个人掉包率
Jake: We should test each person's switch rate later.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈掉包率
Jake: Hahahaha, switch rate.
Jake:掉包率然后呢
Jake: Switch rate, and then...
其他人：嗯我坐了公交车坐了十分钟
Others: Um, I took the bus for ten minutes.
其他人：嗯一共就20分钟
Others: Um, it was a total of 20 minutes.
其他人：嗯坐了十分钟
Others: Um, I took it for ten minutes.
其他人：老师问你个厨房啊
Others: Teacher asked, "Are you in the kitchen?"
其他人：我说我操问你在公交车上
Others: I said, "What the heck, I'm on the bus."
其他人：他说那我挂了你骂
Others: He said, "Then I'll hang up, you bastard."
Tasha: 坐反了
Tasha: Took the wrong way.
其他人：嗯然后他说那还准备一起打车呢
Others: And then he said, "Let's share a cab."
其他人：哦我说那我在那等你吧
Others: Oh, I said, "I'll wait for you there."
其他人：打车好还是骑车好
Others: Is it better to take a cab or bike?
其他人：我说我帮你搜一下
Others: I said, "Let me check for you."
其他人：嗯我他妈一速吊了
Others: Um, I was totally messed up.
其他人：老子怎么时间从20分钟到30分钟啊
Others: How did 20 minutes become 30 minutes?
其他人：哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha.
其他人：然后我就跟他说你在学校门口等我吧
Others: Then I told him, "Wait for me at the school gate."
其他人：我马上打车来刷哦
Others: "I'll catch a cab right away."
Jake:可以
Jake: Okay.
Jake:点撤做饭
Jake: Let's cook some food.
Tasha: 经常公交车坐反
Tasha: I often take the bus the wrong way.
Jake:你也你你你你也坐反
Jake: You also, you, you, you also got on the wrong bus.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake:你是我姐
Jake: You are like my sister.
Jake:你也做反
Tasha: 那我没做反过
Tasha: 我做反那一次是我自己一个人
Tasha: 10岁去南京玩
Tasha: When I was 10, I went to Nanjing for fun.
Jake:嗯嗯
Jake: Hmm hmm.
Jake:你10岁挺猛啊
Tasha: 坐反了我那天一直坐到晚上
Tasha: I got on the wrong bus and ended up riding it until the evening.
Jake:哈哈哈不是你你你坐反了
Jake: Hahaha, no, you, you, you got on the wrong bus.
Tasha: 坐到了大山里
Tasha: I ended up in the mountains.
Tasha: 你知道吗
Tasha: Do you know?
Tasha: 坐那个公交车
Tasha: I was on that bus.
Jake:坐山东去
Jake: You went to Shandong?
Tasha: 当时好像正好是什么会
Tasha: At that time, it seemed like there was some event.
Tasha: 什么北京举办什么会
Tasha: Some event hosted in Beijing.
Tasha: 好多志愿者
Tasha: Lots of volunteers.
Tasha: 我就问他怎么回去
Tasha: I asked them how to get back.
Tasha: 然后他们把我带回去了
Tasha: Then they took me back.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Tasha: 嗯 10岁举办什么会我忘了
Tasha: Hmm, I forgot what event was held when I was 10.
Jake:你你你 10岁你去南京
Jake: You, you, you went to Nanjing at 10.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake:然后北京办一个什么会
Jake: And then Beijing hosted some event.
Tasha: 南京办了什么会
Tasha: Nanjing hosted an event.
Jake:南京南京办一个会啊
Jake: Nanjing, Nanjing hosted an event, huh?
Tasha: 我一直坐反了
Tasha: I was on the wrong bus all the way.
Tasha: 坐到大山里面
Tasha: Ended up in the mountains.
Jake:青奥会青奥会青奥会青奥会志愿者
Jake: The Youth Olympic Games, Youth Olympic Games, Youth Olympic Games volunteers.
Tasha: 坐到大山里
Tasha: Ended up in the mountains.
Tasha: 然后他们最后志愿者
Tasha: Then eventually the volunteers...
Tasha: 在那公交站台的时候
Tasha: At the bus stop...
Tasha: 然后就把我接回去了
Tasha: Then they took me back.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:搞笑哎
Jake: So funny.
Jake:不行我再看看我的手机
Jake: No, let me check my phone again.
Jake:不然马上又给我留人打电话
Jake: Otherwise, someone will call me soon.
Jake:又把我骂一顿
Jake: And scold me again.
Jake:没有他因为他昨天
Jake: No, because yesterday...
Jake:昨天拿东西的时候没接他电话
Jake: Yesterday, I didn't pick up his call while I was getting something.
Jake:回头就把我骂一顿
Jake: He scolded me for it later.
其他人： 她
Others: She
Jake:啊我姐
Jake: Ah, my sister.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha
Tasha: 哇我们真顽强
Tasha: Wow, we're really resilient.
Tasha: 我们居然一路走下来了
Tasha: We actually made it all the way down.
Jake:牛逼
Jake: Awesome.
Tasha: 杨老把剩下钱能不能分摊给咱俩
Tasha: Jake, can you split the remaining money between us?
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Jake:牛逼
Jake: Awesome.
Tasha: 要把这个铲掉吗
Tasha: Should we clear this away?
Jake:他要技术不怎么样的话
Jake: If his skills aren't that great,
Jake:确实有可能
Jake:要爆了
Jake: It's gonna blow.
Tasha: 你会开铲车
Tasha: Can you drive a bulldozer?
Jake:我不会我去
Jake: I can't, I'm out.
Tasha: 哈哈我家有
Tasha: Haha, we have one at home.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Jake:你真是
Jake: You really are...
Tasha: 我家有没有
Tasha: Do we have one at home?
Tasha: 我家真有
Tasha: We really do.
Tasha: 就在我家门口停着
Tasha: It's parked right outside my house.
Jake:哈哈哪天
Jake: Hah, one day...
Tasha: 每天都能开
Tasha: We can drive it every day.
Jake:哪天去你家玩
Jake: One day, I'll visit your place.
Tasha: 好呀我家还有船
Tasha: Sure, we also have a boat.
Jake:组组队去乖乖
Jake: Let's team up and go.
Jake:你家还有船啊
Jake: You have a boat too?
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Tasha: 大运河边上吗
Tasha: Near the Grand Canal?
Tasha: 靠船生活
Tasha: We live off the boat.
Jake:你家是什么
Jake: What's your family?
Tasha: 我们家靠船起家了
Tasha: Our family started from the boat business.
Jake:不是不是
Jake: No, no.
Jake:你刚是开什么叉车
Jake: What were you driving earlier?
Jake:开开什么车
Jake: What kind of vehicle?
Tasha: 开叉车铲车呀
Tasha: Forklift and bulldozer.
Jake:铲车就就这种是吧
Jake: Bulldozer, right, this type?
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah
Jake:啊挖掘机
Jake: Ah, an excavator
Tasha: 我家门口就有
Tasha: There's one right outside my house
Tasha: 然后你猜我们家干什么生意的
Tasha: And guess what business we do
Jake:运
Jake: Transporting
Jake:你家卖盐
Jake: Your family sells salt
Tasha: 就卖这个沙子的
Tasha: We sell this sand
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Tasha: 然后那个船就是用来运沙的
Tasha: And that boat is used to transport the sand
Jake:沙子怎么卖
Jake: How do you sell the sand?
Jake:这沙子怎么卖
Jake: How do you sell this sand?
Tasha: 沙子
Tasha: The sand
Jake:沙子你怎么做啊
Jake: How do you handle the sand?
其他人：你自己处理的吗
Other: Do you process it yourself?
Tasha: 沙子就是从用船运过来的
Tasha: The sand is transported by boat
Tasha: 好像就是把
Tasha: I guess it's just
其他人：你运过来再把它卖走
Other: You transport it and then sell it
其他人：你是中间商
Other: You're a middleman
Jake:你处理什么呀
Jake: What do you process?
Tasha: 对啊我爸说只要只要差价5毛钱一船
Tasha: Yeah, my dad says as long as the price difference is 50 cents per boat
Tasha: 一船沙子就能卖20万
Tasha: One boat of sand can sell for 200,000
Tasha: 哈哈就这5毛钱
Tasha: Haha, just with that 50 cents difference
Jake:就是你们倒卖是吧
Jake: So you guys just resell, right?
Jake:还是什么
Jake: Or what?
Tasha: 就是倒卖吗对啊
Tasha: Yeah, we just resell it
Jake:呵呵呵可以
Jake: Haha, that's possible
Tasha: 5毛钱差价就能赚20万
Tasha: A 50 cent difference can earn 200,000
Jake:可以
Jake: That works
其他人：现在有多少人差价
Other: How many people are making that difference now?
Tasha: 不知道我爸说生意没以前好做了
Tasha: I don't know, my dad says business isn't as good as before
Tasha: 以前一个月卖一以前一个月卖一船
Tasha: We used to sell one boat a month
Tasha: 现在好像不知道几个月卖一船
Tasha: Now, I don't know, maybe one boat every few months
Jake:对以前是做生意
Jake: Yeah, it used to be a good business
Tasha: 以前生意就是房地产好的那会
Tasha: It was good when the real estate market was booming
Jake:哦哦哦建大楼
Jake: Oh, building skyscrapers
Tasha: 一个月卖一船啊
Tasha: One boat a month
Jake:现在没大楼建了
Jake: Now there are no skyscrapers being built
Tasha: 然后好几辆船停在我们家旁边
Tasha: And several boats are parked next to our house
Jake:然后巴闭吧
Jake: And they're just sitting there, huh?
Tasha: 然后每天都在铲哈哈
Jake:呵呵发币吧
Jake: Haha, let's issue some currency.
Tasha: 偶尔我也会帮忙铲铲
Jake:偶尔开开挖机
Jake: Occasionally, I also operate the excavator.
Jake:是吧对
Jake: Right, yeah.
Tasha: 会开开
Tasha: I can operate it.
Jake:真牛逼
Jake: That's really impressive.
Jake:这个要驾照啊
Jake: Do you need a license for that?
Tasha: 这个这个
Tasha: This, this...
Tasha: 自己在自己家开
Tasha: I operate it at home.
Tasha: 不要驾照吧
Tasha: No need for a license, right?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 就是自己家有一个运沙场
Tasha: We have a sand yard at home.
Jake:也不会上路啊
Jake: You don't take it on the road, right?
Jake:这个应该不会上路吧
Jake: You wouldn't take it on the road, right?
其他人：这里还有一个运沙场
Others: There's another sand yard here.
Tasha: 就是运沙子的地方呀
Tasha: It's just a place for hauling sand.
Jake:这这个
Jake: This, this...
Jake:你你家多大呀
Jake: How big is your place?
Tasha: 我家多大
Tasha: How big is my place?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: I don't know.
Jake:不知道啊
Jake: You don't know?
Jake:好无边无际啊
Jake: It's so vast.
Tasha: 没有人的区
Tasha: It's an uninhabited area.
Tasha: 都给我们家堆沙子了
Tasha: All the sand is piled up in our place.
Jake:哦这么回事那
Jake: Oh, I see.
Jake:那是真的我看
Jake: That's true, I think.
Tasha: 在海边能有几个人住
Tasha: How many people can live by the sea?
Tasha: 不是海边
Tasha: Not by the sea.
Tasha: 湖边河边
Tasha: By the lake or river.
其他人：在哪里啊
Others: Where is it?
Tasha: 大运河边
Tasha: By the Grand Canal.
Jake:京杭大运河
Jake: The Beijing-Hangzhou Grand Canal.
Jake:这个我懂
Jake: I know that.
其他人：什么城市
Others: Which city?
Jake:扬州啊
Jake: Yangzhou.
其他人：扬州
Others: Yangzhou.
Jake:没有江苏人这种东西
Jake: There's no such thing as a Jiangsu person.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 你们家经商吗
Tasha: Does your family do business?
Jake:我我们家不经商
Jake: My family doesn't do business.
Tasha: 你们家干嘛的
Tasha: What does your family do?
Jake:我们家
Jake: My family...
Tasha: 怪不得怪不得
Tasha: No wonder, no wonder.
Tasha: 因为我们家都经商
Tasha: Because my family is all in business.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:我们家干嘛的
Jake: What does my family do?
Tasha: 你们家干嘛的
Tasha: What does your family do?
Jake:我们家坐办公室的
Jake: My family works in offices.
Tasha: 坐办公室的全部都是啊真好
Tasha: Everyone works in offices? That's great.
Jake:嗯全坐办公室的
Jake: Yeah, everyone works in offices.
Jake:这不好玩没
Jake: Isn't that boring?
Jake:没有叉车要
Jake: No forklifts needed.
Tasha: 要要什么好啊
Tasha: What's so good about forklifts?
Jake:没叉车坐啊
Jake:没有叉车坐
Tasha: 你要叉车座干嘛
Tasha: What do you need forklift seats for?
Jake:那不是牛逼啊
Jake: Isn't that cool?
Shure: 呦你们回来了啊
Shure: Oh, you guys are back.
Jake:有电吗你们啊
Jake: Do you guys have power?
Jake:你们有电吗
Jake: Do you have power?
Shure: 你没电了啊
Shure: You ran out of power?
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Huh?
Shure: 你这么用心的摸鱼居然没被发现天
Shure: You're slacking off so diligently without getting caught, amazing.
Shure: 哎别提了
Shure: Oh, don't mention it.
Shure: 杨老板我在这兢兢业业的收拾辫子
Shure: Jake, I'm here working hard on braids.
Jake:哎呀没关系
Jake: Oh, it's fine.
Shure: 就在这坐着摸鱼
Shure: Just sitting here slacking off.
Jake:呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe.
Alice:快递回来了吗
Alice: Has the package arrived?
Jake:快递回来了
Jake: The package has arrived.
Alice: 这是我的啥
Alice: What is this of mine?
Jake:这是什么呀
Jake: What is this?
Alice:小雏菊
Alice: Daisies.
Shure: daisy
Shure: Daisy.
Katrina: 呵呵很高级
Katrina: Hehe, very fancy.
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha.
Jake:什么5块钱啊
Jake: What's 5 bucks?
其他人：猕猴桃都5块了哦
Others: Kiwis are 5 bucks now.
Shure: 就是这个大瓶
Shure: It's this big bottle.
Shure: 就是原来他500毫升是卖3块钱
Shure: It used to be 3 yuan for 500 milliliters.
Tasha: 4块
Tasha: 4 yuan.
Shure: 然后一升的卖4块钱
Shure: And then 4 yuan for a liter.
Shure: 然后所以
Shure: So...
Shure: 大家称这个4块钱这个为屌丝饮料
Shure: People called this 4 yuan drink a low-end drink.
Jake:哦 4块钱还屌丝
Jake: Oh, 4 yuan is still considered low-end?
Jake:两个EO币呢
Jake: Two EO coins then.
Jake:我靠呵呵呵
Jake: Oh man, haha.
Shure: 然后然后现在这个涨价涨到5块
Shure: And now it has increased to 5 yuan.
Shure: 大家纷纷喊买不起了
Shure: Everyone is saying they can't afford it anymore.
Jake:呵呵呵真屌丝
Jake: Haha, truly low-end.
Shure: （歌词）有人随着风去
Shure: (singing) Someone follows the wind...
Alice:OK了我的齐了谢谢你
Alice: OK, I'm done, thank you.
Jake:谢谢哎好谢谢
Jake: Thanks, great, thanks.
Shure: 这不都我做的吗
Shure: Didn't I do all of this?
Alice:要不我给这拆了吧
Alice: Should I take this apart?
其他人：操这么屌
Others: Wow, so cool.
其他人：我做的厉害吧
Others: Did I do great or what?
Jake:来我帮你
Jake: Let me help you.
Alice:没事没事
Alice: It's okay, it's okay.
Jake:牛
Jake: Impressive.
Jake:我来看看
Jake: Let me take a look.
Jake:哇这么这么牛逼
Jake: Wow, so awesome!
Katrina: 哈哈哈他的感叹词都好匮乏
Katrina: Haha, his expressions are so limited.
Jake:哈哈哈爱自己是终身浪漫的开始
Jake: Haha, loving oneself is the beginning of a lifelong romance.
Shure: 爱自己是终身浪漫的开始
Shure: Loving oneself is the beginning of a lifelong romance.
Shure: 这个很好看
Shure: This looks great.
Shure: 我要这个
Shure: I want this one.
Shure: 卧槽这好帅啊这些
Shure: Wow, these are so cool.
其他人：0.5个EGO
Others: 0.5 EGO.
Shure: 别赶路赶受路哇哦
Shure: Don't rush the journey, enjoy it. Wow.
Tasha: 还剩下几天
Tasha: How many days are left?
Tasha: 不就剩下两天吗
Tasha: Isn't it just two days left?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Jake:人均没电
Jake: Out of power for everyone.
Jake:挺好啊没电了吗
Jake: That's good, no power left?
Lucia: 嗯啊看来我接线还是
Lucia: Hmm, looks like I connected it too late.
Lucia: 接晚了啊
Lucia: Connected it too late, huh?
Jake:没关系
Jake: No worries.
Lucia: 刚下来要发信息
Lucia: Just came down, need to send a message.
Jake:没关系没关系
Jake: It's okay, it's okay.
Lucia: 既然没电了
Lucia: Since it's out of power,
Lucia: 要再开一个吗
Lucia: Should we turn on another one?
Jake:开一个开呀开
Jake: Turn on another one, yes, turn it on.
Jake:谢谢开什么
Jake: Thank you, turn on what?
Lucia: 开一个新的
Lucia: Turn on a new one.
Jake:开好嗯
Jake: Turn it on, okay.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Tasha: 拆快递
Tasha: Unboxing.
Jake:徒手拆快递表演
Jake: Unboxing performance with bare hands.
Jake:一个徒手拆快递
Tasha: 拿剪刀了我
Tasha: I'm getting the scissors.
Jake:哎你的那个线呢
Jake: Hey, where's your cable?
Jake:你自己的线你知道在哪吗
Jake: Do you know where your cable is?
Tasha: 我的现在我的包里
Tasha: It's in my bag now.
Tasha: 我的包在我的包里
Tasha: My bag, it's in my bag.
Jake:你的包里楼上呢
Jake: Is your bag upstairs?
Tasha: 楼上呢
Tasha: Upstairs.
Jake:好那你去拿吧
Jake: Okay, then go get it.
Jake:你先去哪
Jake: Where are you going first?
Katrina: 拍卖
Katrina: Auction.
Katrina: 修硕那个的亲笔签名拍卖
Katrina: Shure's autographed item up for auction.
Katrina: 从1亿个币
Katrina: Starting at 1 billion coins.
Jake:修欢修数修卡
Jake: Shure, Shure, Shure.
Jake:哈哈哈我看啊看啊
Jake: Haha, let me see, let me see.
Tasha: 哦我说我的剪刀呢
Tasha: Oh, where are my scissors?
Jake:这这什么呀
Jake: What's this?
Jake:白鸟词典
Jake: White Bird Dictionary.
Shure: 鸟词典
Shure: Bird Dictionary.
Tasha: 对这是我行李箱里带的
Tasha: Yes, I brought it in my suitcase.
Jake:鸟在哪啊
Jake: Where's the bird?
Shure: 鸟
Shure: Bird.
Shure: 然后这是繁体的那个言字旁
Shure: And then this is the traditional character with the speech radical.
Shure: 然后配合上这边是词
Shure: And then this part is the word.
Jake:噢噢噢
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Shure: 然后把这所有都遮住
Shure: And then cover all this.
Shure: 这是个点
Shure: This is a dot.
Tasha: 哦哦
Tasha: Oh, oh.
Jake:可以是吧
Jake: Is that okay?
Shure: 是吧这个
Shure: Right, this...
Shure: 我绞尽脑汁想了半天
Shure: I've been racking my brains for a long time.
Jake:这花多少钱
Jake: How much did this cost?
Shure: 这是我自己写的
Shure: I wrote this myself.
Jake:哦不值钱是吧
Jake: Oh, it's not worth much then?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 更值钱了吧不应该
Shure: It's worth even more, isn't it?
Jake:好好更值钱
Jake: Okay, okay, it's worth more.
Jake:值钱值钱
Jake: It's worth a lot.
Jake:有 可能
Jake: Maybe.
Tasha: 56 就是一家
Tasha: 56 is just one family.
Jake:你知道他叫什么吗
Jake: Do you know his name?
Jake:英文名
Jake: His English name.
Shure: 他吗
Shure: His?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:他叫他叫古希腊
Jake: His name is Ancient Greece.
Shure: 真的吗
Shure: Really?
Jake:真的吗他叫古希腊对
Jake: Really, his name is Ancient Greece, right.
Jake:这
Jake: This...
Jake:叫古希腊
Jake: Called Ancient Greece.
其他人：你觉得是没油了还是打火石
Others: Do you think it's out of fuel or the flint?
其他人：还是没油了
Others: Or is it out of fuel?
其他人：  应该是没油了没油了
Others: It must be out of fuel, out of fuel.
Jake:哎你线拿下来了
Jake: Hey, you took the wire down.
Shure: 加点酒精吧要不哈哈
Shure: Add some alcohol, maybe, haha.
Lucia: 哇好可爱
Lucia: Wow, so cute.
Shure: 哈不会
Shure: Haha, no way.
Shure: 他只会整个都烧起来
Shure: It'll just burn the whole thing.
Jake:挺好天晴挺暖和挺暖和的
Jake: It's nice, sunny and warm, very warm.
Jake:我看看去
Jake: Let me take a look.
Jake:我是个
Jake: I'm a...
Jake:我看看我是个什么东西
Jake: Let me see, what am I?
Tasha: 特丑
Tasha: Super ugly.
Jake:确实挺好看
Jake: It actually looks pretty good.
Tasha: 是吧
Tasha: Right?
Jake:是吧挺潮的确实
Jake: Right? It's pretty trendy, really.
Shure: 太潮了真的
Shure: Super trendy, really.
Shure: 你今天就这样
Shure: Are you going like this today?
Jake:我就我今天就这样
Jake: Yeah, I'm going like this today.
Jake:这是一个大勋章是不是
Jake: This is a big medal, right?
Jake:这是这是
Jake: This is, this is
Shure: 这是你可以叫supernova超新星
Shure: You can call this supernova
Tasha: 还有只短腿的
Tasha: There's also a short-legged one
Jake:哪呢这个
Jake: Where is this one?
Jake:这就是短腿的
Jake: This is the short-legged one
Jake:哦这长腿
Jake: Oh, this is the long-legged one
Shure: 倒
Shure: Fell down
Shure: 北邮也火了
Shure: Beiyou is trending now
Shure: 怎么着火了是吗
Shure: Why is it trending?
Jake:这个是长腿
Jake: This one is long-legged
Shure: 阳台抽烟把把衣服点着了
Shure: Someone was smoking on the balcony and set the clothes on fire
Jake:我靠
Jake: Oh my god
Jake:这什么地方啊沙河
Jake: Where is this place? Shahe?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:面包大学是什么
Jake: What is Bread University?
Shure: 不知道什么叫面包大学
Shure: You don't know what Bread University is?
Jake:给你运上去
Jake: Let me send it up to you
Shure: 老学长们都已经不懂这个梗了是吧
Shure: Even the senior alumni don't understand this joke, right?
Jake:确实不懂
Jake: I really don't get it
Jake:你知道吗
Jake: Do you know?
Shure: 我也不知道
Shure: I don't know either
Jake:那你们也老学长
Shure: 我也老学长了
Shure: I'm also a senior alumni
Jake:不懂沙河的这些梗
Jake: Don't get these Shahe jokes
Jake:丰收
Jake: Harvest
Jake:哎呦我去
Jake: Oh my gosh
Jake:哎呦哈哈
Jake: Oh haha
Jake:哎呦我操
Jake: Oh shit
Jake:哈哈妙啊
Jake: Haha, brilliant
Jake:哈哈这是命运这是命这是
Jake: Haha, this is fate, this is destiny
Lucia: 哦然后就那个大门他就像这样
Lucia: Oh and then the big door was like this
Lucia: 还有一个这个
Lucia: And there's this one too
Lucia: 嗯嗯然后我就有个书包进来
Lucia: Mm-hmm, and then I had a backpack on
Lucia: 这刚好放在书包袋子上
Lucia: It was just hanging on the backpack strap
Lucia: 我先进了门
Lucia: I went through the door first
Lucia: 他一边跟我讲话一边往里走
Lucia: He was talking to me and walking in
Jake:其实挂那了
Jake: Actually, it was hanging there
Lucia: 哈哈走着走着哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha, walking and walking, haha
Jake:他要再设计好一点自动脱包
Jake: If it was designed better, it could automatically unhook the bag
Lucia: 特别好笑
Lucia: That's really funny
Lucia: 因为你就是
Lucia: Because you are...
Lucia: 你不知道的时候你整你整体是往前的
Lucia: When you don't know, you're overall moving forward.
Jake:对对
Jake: Yes, yes.
Lucia: 往后的立
Lucia: Leaning back.
Lucia: 就像你走在地上正正常的走着
Lucia: It's like you're walking normally on the ground.
Lucia: 突然有人啪把你往后一拉
Lucia: And suddenly someone pulls you back.
Jake:就就这样
Jake: Just like that.
Lucia: 对对对哈哈哈
Lucia: Yes, yes, yes, hahaha.
Lucia: 不是不是因为你们学的时候是白神
Lucia: No, no, because when you were learning, you were like a rookie.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 你好像有一些非常神奇的技能点
Lucia: You seem to have some really magical skills.
Jake:哦是吗
Jake: Oh, really?
Lucia: 是的
Lucia: Yes.
Jake:你好
Jake: Hello.
Jake:我我姐今天又又又破防了
Jake: My sister got upset again today.
Jake:又又又给我们整破防了
Jake: She made us all upset again.
Lucia: 怎么了说说看
Lucia: What happened? Tell us.
其他人：我爱爱听
Others: I love to listen.
其他人：爱听一些别人洞房故事
Others: Love to hear other people's stories.
Jake:哈哈哈这什么来着
Jake: Hahaha, what's this?
Jake:我靠
Jake: Oh my.
Jake:首首先首先是路上看到一个挖掘机
Jake: First, we saw an excavator on the road.
Jake:然后问我开没开过
Jake: Then she asked me if I had ever driven one.
Lucia: 你开过我没开过
Lucia: Have you? I haven't.
Lucia: 他开过哈哈
Lucia: He has, haha.
Lucia: 哇为什么啊
Lucia: Wow, why?
Lucia: 好神奇
Lucia: So amazing.
Jake:开开挖机
Jake: Driving an excavator.
Jake:各种还有啥来着
Jake: Various things, what else was there?
Lucia: 我觉得开挖掘机很帅
Lucia: I think driving an excavator is cool.
Jake:我也觉得
Jake: I think so too.
Jake:我都没动过
Jake: I've never tried it.
Jake:我也想开挖机
Jake: I want to drive an excavator.
Lucia: 我家有一个乐高挖掘机
Lucia: I have a LEGO excavator at home.
Jake:哈哈你也开过
Jake: Haha, you drove it too.
Jake:你也开过
Jake: You drove it too.
Tasha: 我们家有挖机
Tasha: We have an excavator at home.
Tasha: 去我家开
Tasha: Come to my house and drive it.
Jake:哈哈我不光开过
Jake: Haha, not only did I drive it.
Lucia: 我不光开过
Lucia: 我还造过
Lucia: I've even made it myself.
Jake:你造过嗯
Jake: You've made it, huh?
Lucia: 我亲手一块一块做吧
Lucia: I made it piece by piece with my own hands.
Jake:哦OK
Jake: Oh, okay.
Lucia: 就很tricky吧
Lucia: It's pretty tricky, right?
Lucia: 就像我本科损失两辆车一样是是
Lucia: Just like when I lost two cars during my undergrad years.
Tasha: 等我装饰房间的呢
Tasha: Wait, I'm decorating the room.
Jake:怎么搞what should i do
Jake: What should I do?
Tasha: what to do
Tasha: What to do?
Jake:what should i do
Jake: What should I do?
Tasha: 把快递先都拆了
Tasha: Unpack all the packages first.
Tasha: 然后拿上来
Tasha: Then bring them up.
Jake:好好
Jake: Alright, alright.
Tasha: 然后开始装饰
Tasha: Then we can start decorating.
Jake:好好
Jake: Okay, okay.
Jake:你现在插的是你的线还是我的线
Jake: Are you plugging in your cable or mine?
Tasha: 我现在插的
Tasha: I'm plugging in...
Jake:啊
Jake: Huh?
Tasha: 插的是我的生命
Tasha: I'm plugging in my lifeline.
Tasha: 你的生命线
Tasha: Your lifeline.
Jake:我的生命线了
Jake: My lifeline.
Tasha: 是的我的生命线在楼下
Tasha: Yeah, my lifeline is downstairs.
Jake:好的
Jake: Got it.
Jake:我没生命线了
Jake: I'm out of lifelines.
Tasha: 那你完了
Tasha: Then you're done for.
Jake:古希腊怎么拼
Jake: How do you spell Ancient Greece?
Katrina: 确实啊在哪呢
Katrina: Indeed, where is it?
Katrina: 刚起的
Katrina: Just started.
Jake:咔哇咔cartrina
Jake: Kawaka, Katrina.
Jake:okay cartrina
Jake: Okay, Katrina.
Tasha: 知道这是什么吗
Tasha: Do you know what this is?
Jake:这纸眼睛
Jake: This paper eye.
Tasha: 这个
Tasha: This.
Tasha: 你知道这眼睛怎么用吗
Tasha: Do you know how to use these eyes?
Jake:贴眼睛上
Jake: Stick it on the eye.
Tasha: 贴在哪都会很有灵魂
Tasha: Stick it anywhere, it will be soulful.
Jake:贴在哪都会很有灵魂
Jake: Stick it anywhere, it will be soulful.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:贴眼睛上
Jake: Stick it on the eye.
Jake:你把你手机拿出来好嘞
Jake: Take out your phone, alright.
Jake:你这线是谁的线
Jake: Whose cable is this?
Shure: 我的呀
Shure: It's mine.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 怎么了
Shure: What's up?
Jake:那这线是谁的线
Jake: Then whose cable is this?
Tasha: 我的那你的线是谁的线
Tasha: It's mine. Then whose cable is yours?
Jake:我的那你的线是谁的线
Jake: It's mine. Then whose cable is yours?
Jake:你的那我这根线是谁的线我靠
Jake: Yours. Then whose cable is this? Damn.
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Damn.
Jake:我看看我去
Jake: Let me see, damn.
Jake:挺可爱我看看你的线是什么线
Jake: So cute. Let me see what kind of cable you have.
Jake:你这线是我的线
Jake: Your cable is my cable.
Tasha: 可爱吧你想要什么
Tasha: Cute, right? What do you want?
Tasha: 都可以你想要几百个
Tasha: Anything you want, hundreds of them.
Tasha: 哪都可以贴
Tasha: You can stick them anywhere.
Jake:哪都可以吃
Jake: You can eat them anywhere.
Tasha: 贴上就注入了灵魂
Tasha: Stick them on and they have a soul.
Tasha: 给你两个大眼睛
Tasha: I'll give you two big eyes.
Jake:我的线是你的线
Jake: My cable is your cable.
Shure: 我靠这还有安格斯厚牛堡都没吃呢
Shure: Damn, we still have Angus thick beef burgers we haven't eaten.
Shure: 对啊太败家了吧
Shure: Yeah, that's so wasteful.
Jake:对啊
Jake: Yeah.
Shure: 这一帮帮的
Shure: This whole group.
Alice:这帮垃圾
Alice: This bunch of trash.
Jake:还有两个
Jake: There are still two.
Jake:两个
Jake: Two.
Shure: 我两个我操
Shure: Two? Damn it.
Shure: 太太过分了
Shure: That's way too much.
Shure: 这么好的东西不吃我天
Shure: Such good stuff, not eating it, my gosh.
Jake:咋办炒的吧
Jake: What should we do, fry it?
Jake:要不什么炒
Jake: Or what, fry it?
Shure: 什么炒了
Shure: Fry what?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 拿微波炉叮一下不就得了还炒了
Shure: Just microwave it, no need to fry.
Katrina: 这可以直接这样充吗
Katrina: Can I charge it directly like this?
Shure: 可以
Shure: Yes.
Jake:可以呃可以可以
Jake: Yes, uh yes, yes.
Jake:确实确实可以确实可以
Jake: Definitely, definitely can.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure: 怎么怎么打扫呢
Shure: How to clean this?
Shure: 杨老板可以在这立个固定机位
Shure: Jake, you can set up a fixed camera here.
Jake:哎
Jake: Eh?
Shure: 拍个延时视频
Shure: To shoot a time-lapse video.
Shure: 我们在这酷酷收拾那什么
Jake:哦哦哦这都有啊
Jake: Oh, we have all this here?
Jake:这一圈都可以拍
Jake: You can shoot all around here.
Shure: 啊也也是对
Shure: Yeah, that's right.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Tasha: 对啊哈哈哈他连你下面的都想要
Tasha: Yeah, hahaha, he even wants the stuff below you.
Jake:这下面的现在应该还能买的到
Jake: You can probably still buy the stuff below.
Jake:对当时我觉得能买到也挺牛逼的
Jake: Yeah, back then I thought it was pretty cool to be able to buy it.
Tasha: 要不要给你眼镜上贴两个超小的
Tasha: How about putting two tiny ones on your glasses?
Jake:怎么贴
Jake: How do you stick them?
Jake:我靠这个是比目鱼
Jake: Whoa, this is a flounder.
Jake:这是什么鱼
Jake: What kind of fish is this?
Jake:掌掌掌两边的鱼是指什么鱼
Jake: What kind of fish are the ones on both sides?
其他人：别墅手感还挺好
Others: The villa feels pretty nice.
Tasha: 现在就给你一个命令
Tasha: Now I'm giving you a command.
Tasha: 把家里所有的能贴上眼镜的
Tasha: Put glasses on everything in the house.
Tasha: 都注入灵魂
Tasha: And give them all souls.
Jake:我靠
Jake: Whoa.
Tasha: 现在把手上贴两个戴在门口
Tasha: Now stick two on your hands and place them at the door.
Jake:再等等这边贴两个
Jake: Wait a sec, put two here.
Jake:迎接一下客人哈哈
Jake: To welcome the guests, haha.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:把门上贴两个
Jake: Stick two on the door.
Jake:修硕眼睛上贴两个
Tasha: 这不是我的
Tasha: These aren't mine.
Tasha: 哦这还是我的
Tasha: Oh, these are mine.
Jake:那
Jake: Then...
Jake:开玩笑我们走了一路全是泪
其他人：这个是什么
Others: What is this?
Tasha: 不知道很可爱吧
Tasha: No idea, it's cute though.
Tasha: 不知道是什么
Tasha: No idea what it is.
Jake:餐布野餐野餐用的早
Jake:拿来咱拿去野餐
Jake: Let's take it for a picnic.
Jake:浴袍床单
Jake: Bathrobe, bedsheets.
Tasha: 就是挺好看的
Tasha: They do look pretty nice.
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Jake:这是哪个民族啊
Jake: Which ethnic group is this from?
Jake:甜品民族
Jake: Dessert nation
Jake:甜品族
Jake: Dessert tribe
Jake:我觉得挺好
Jake: I think it's pretty good
Jake:这饭就到位了
Jake: This meal is perfect
其他人：这个中有什么故事啊
Others: What's the story behind this?
Tasha: 不知道
Tasha: No idea
Jake:这钟这么小
Jake: This clock is so small
Jake:好看反了
Jake: It looks amazing
Jake:好看
Jake: Looks great
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Tasha: 5号电池
Tasha: AA battery
其他人：还得是你
Others: It's all you
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Jake:还得是你
Jake: It's all you
Jake:不是一个够的都对不起你
Jake: One isn't enough to do you justice
Tasha: 我们屁人就是讲究机缘巧合
Tasha: We just believe in serendipity
Tasha: 这什么好看
Tasha: What's so great about this?